greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happened now is brought to you
by on it listen for all your supplements
on it is there for you whether it's the
alpha brain the shroom tech sport or the
shroom tech immune my favorites alpha
brain when it comes to listen you know a
hundred percent money-back guarantee if
you don't like the alpha brain and guess
what you don't even have to send the
product back that's just pilots about
when they put some I wasn't last time
you went to a Chinese restaurant they
said if you don't like the egg roll you
give it back no it don't work that way
but on it makes it work because they
believe in their products go to Anna
comrade now look at the fine line of
something to say have if you find
something pressing Church CH you are CH
a check out and get 10% off delivered to
your house also let me tell you I'm
uncle Jesus uncle Joey's gonna tell you
don't cut your dick off [ __ ] off the
suffering and the depression ends now
with manscaped you get it done without
the pain what a pain are you talking
about Joey the pain of that [ __ ] bush
and that stink growing between your legs
you got to cut the bush off summer is
coming [ __ ] everybody wants to
get their dick sucked but it smells like
a dead goat go to manscape right now
they got premium tools for the family
jewels manscaped has redesigned he likes
you crazy so you get all the nooks and
crannies where the stink develops where
the stink starts you understand me you
want chicks to suck your balls but they
taste like [ __ ] sour cream would you
suck on balls and taste like sour cream
no it's going to manscape they got the
[ __ ] solution for your problems at
manscape calm you get everything you
need to make your ball shine and keep
your dick looking like [ __ ] cleopatra
you understand me now listen the fact
the church family gets 20% off your
first order when you use promo code
Church CH you are CH at manscape that
time and if you order the perfect
package which I tell you about later
they also throw in a free travel bag
when you use the promo code Church
that's manscape com use promo code
church for 20% off your first order you
got to keep your balls clean the
summer's coming
take this [ __ ] at me at least
it's the Church of what's happening on
my
Manman is here today mr. Nick ball along
do you guys like scratching and who's
Nick Vallelunga
academy-award-winning Nick while I Wanda
you [ __ ] up does the green book how are
you my dear friend though I finally
figured out where I met in the whole
situation we you and I did a horrible
movie together in 2012 but I would not
discuss on TV on this exempt are you
being here we did a movie called Jersey
Shore shark at all
yes I think the next day Paulie walnuts
was showing up yes or something I only
that's right
I forgot about the 2012 wouldn't even do
the movie because of cocaine money he
did the movie cuz the guys had put me in
like eight other movies they really did
the guys really put me in like six
movies seven or eight and that was the
eighth one and when they called me I
really good we got something perfect for
you
oh god that's alright that's where we
met that's not about that that's why I
mention yes and then I Chi I don't know
first I kept saying for years after the
movie came out the Green Book a dear
dear friend listen I haven't been in
contact with movies in years you know
he's just too busy yeah you're bigger
than know you've just been too busy to
watch TV like there was a time next I
grew up in the movie theater so did you
would you grow up the Bronx I grew up in
the Bronx and injures okay you grew up
and I'm over Dean I was an usher on
Saturdays you can't wait for a [ __ ]
movie to come on that's right but uh now
who has the time I wish I had the time
to go to two movies a week and sit and
argue at you about the act and he didn't
do it right I love the time you're right
yeah I joined that Club you know you pay
one one fee can go to three movies a
week because I thought oh kidding me I
can get my money's worth
I hardly barely have a chance to go
anymore I used to go all the time I want
to go see every movie that came out when
I worked in a movie theater for years
and the best part was you got free
movies I saw everything for Zach for
five years you couldn't wait to see a
[ __ ] riot and now it's like the movie
comes out and you already I don't know
if it's called jaded but you see that
you you see the trailer and you make
your decision up right they're like I'm
not gonna see that there's always some
my [ __ ] time all you don't see the
trail
dear friend of mine Mike Bartoli well
known that dirty is called me for like
months and he kept telling me you see
the green book
did you see the green book I'm like Mike
when the [ __ ] do I have time you don't
know love it go see the green go see and
he works for Frankie Valli no okay so go
see degree imma go see the green book
and finally I got on the point and
watched it it was on I was [ __ ] blow
you know when they said sir bachelors
and I was definitely gonna watch it yeah
he's my little brother that I - watch it
and you wrote something that touched the
[ __ ] out of me you know I see I think
the movie was supposed to be based in 63
yes 60 62 1960s so funny when I came
from Cuban 65 and I came from Cuban 66
when I was five but it from the ages of
five to seven I hung out with an
african-american kid my mother had a bar
on a 27 an autobot and that made me
think i wish i could find this kid today
and hug him because his family took me
into their home in 68 and 69 you kept to
yourself and the brothers kept enough
that so that's it's just out of the
cultural that's how the culture was then
they had all the brothers had the afro
picks with the fistin and they put in
their back pocket you live wrong New
York the Italians were in one section
Jewish people who own section the Irish
were in a section the black people in a
section it's just the way it was because
they were tribal everyone stayed with
their own that's just how how it was
during that time the 30s and 40s but I
still remember walking from his house in
the pride just hunting 25th Street and
him getting [ __ ] for bringing a white
kid into the neighborhood and then
walking it away from her 25th and as you
got 235th white people would say [ __ ] to
me for walking around with him like they
still weren't right you know depending
where we went what color you know it's
like when you bring him in the [ __ ]
neighborhood for leave him outside the
store [ __ ] like that my hello no yeah
crazy till today my daughter is six and
if I tell my daughter hey what do you
think of the black guy she should look
she looked me straight in the face and
go all the guy with glasses on she
doesn't see color and that's good so
unless you
teach your child that [ __ ] they don't
see it that's a lie cuz I didn't see it
at first I heard about it years later
when I moved to Jersey got no choice
well you knew the Jersey they just tell
you right out you respect yeah you know
they don't give a [ __ ] this well an
opening scene was crazy where the two
plumbers came over and threw away the
glasses that was what was important to
show that because even my father you
know to show my father in that light but
I discussed that with my father and we
had a show
it shows what was going on at the time
even though he wasn't a bad person he
was still he was still a product of his
environment and his culture and he
changed see that's the point of the
movie that people can change and learn
so that's what that's why that had to be
in the movie I'll be the first time you
dad told you that story well I met dr.
Shirlee when I was like five I ate my
father took me up to Carnegie Hall
exactly what you see in the movie uh
above the cloudy Hall he had this
amazing penthouse suite with the grand
piano chandeliers all the artifacts the
African artifacts he came out an
amazingly beautiful African robe and so
that was like walking into oz you know
what I mean so I never forgot that and
then you know when I was doing my teens
when he told me the story but I
remembered the Christmas Eve when he
came over I remembered that I was little
by room but definitely remember that him
what coming into the apartment what did
you family think was it like in the
movie that much receptive pull up a
chair oh yeah what everybody froze once
he came in yeah the Fertile comedic
moment where everyone freezes but once
he came in you know my mother and my
family was loving Italians it's once
someone's in the home that sit down eat
you know so you know I remember that
very well I'm the first time we met on
that set and you came up to me and told
me he was your dad I gotta tell you
something he was one of my all-time
favorite gangsters and I'd say this in
the hall since Saturday I laid my eyes
on him the first
an appropriate grounded religion yeah
and he said something so deep and that
movie at the time I was [ __ ] around
with loan sharks my whole life was just
just torturing to launch our science
borrower from one borrower and from the
other and that why and he said how come
nobody keeps me waiting when they're
looking to borrow yeah that line stuck
with me forever because it's you yeah
when people want to borrow money from
you they call you I'm gonna be that five
they get there at ten to five yeah there
could be a blizzard two snowstorms their
mother got hit by lightning all the
excuses they give you when it's time to
pay you the money
yeah oh you're not gonna believe what
happened like my goat ate the cash the
bus went to the wrong place
so for me hearing that [ __ ] cracked
me up it flowed off his tongue oh my god
really it's that little experience with
it wasn't the second line of the [ __ ]
move because he's back there waiting for
you and Mickey Rourke goes back there
how long had your dad been acting we
started with the Godfather so uh he was
working the Copa and I guess it either
Francis Ford Coppola or the casting
director with the John Moe Fred rules
they think producers they went into the
Copa to see some gangsters and hang out
and they brought my father's the one who
was gonna intercede introduce him to
some people and they asked him to be in
the movie that was the first movie and
you and the Godfather oh yeah because
then once he got in then they said to me
got kids we need Italian kids we didn't
have this big wedding scene and so my
brother and I had a go screen test for
it and we got in with like the little
kids in the wedding scene how was that
well for me it was for whatever reason
it just I loved it from the middle I was
there I just knew this is what I want to
do for the rest of my life make movies I
always loved movies as a little kid to
see it made to be there was at the house
at Staten Island to see that the walls
were fake one day I saw them taking them
wall apart so what the hell are you
doing and then they took an apartment so
that the wall was only paper-thin you
know on two sides it was just wood in
between I couldn't believe what I was
seeing that
this is all fake this is uh was crazy it
was something else
you guys were talking about a bad movie
that you were both in but you're like
and I know you were probably too young
but when you were on like The Godfather
and then the green book that that won
Best Picture
is there a feeling when you're on like a
movie like that that's like this is
gonna be an amazing me this is different
from the other movies well luckily I've
been I I did a lot of extra work in New
York I thought was my film school you
know I I didn't care about extra 9xj New
York is a little different you had
people that were doing Broadway then
they're doing extra work during the day
and you got to know the ADEs the same
guys would work in New York so movie or
TV show would come in it's the same guys
so after a while doing so much extra
work they get to know you they see who
has a brain in their head who's not an
idiot you know just talking all the time
so then look some would come up
sometimes on the set they need a guy to
say a line they need a cop to do some
they go Nick come in and sue because
they knew I was an idiot but so doing
the extra work I learned I watched I
stood back but I was in The Godfather
that was all when I was a kid then when
I get older I was in things like put see
Zhanna I was in Goodfellas you know I
just what you know sitting sitting in
the met film I did my kid thing the name
of it with Sean Connery and Dustin
Hoffman just what every film that they
did in the city I was in it somewhere
you know Goodfellas I was my father's in
a good part in Goodfellas he was in the
whole movie but I did I was there for
the COPO scenes I'm supposed to be part
of ray Liotta's crew like he had his own
little crew young guys so we're in the
Copa scenes you don't really see me and
then I was in the prison scenes and I'm
with Ray we shot some stuff that didn't
make the movie but when his wife comes
in I'm sitting like behind him saying
watching him from a tail I'm right there
with him we did a bunch of stuff there
so I didn't get a chance to talk to Ray
when we saw him last but yeah I did that
was Ray Liotta now
your dad passed into 12 2013 in 2013 and
I'm sure he's missed by a lot of people
how long have you been discussing the
script for a green book well I you know
I interviewed him in like 1989-90 who's
that with my father and then I tape
recorded cassette you know then he said
okay we have to talk to dr. show you
gotta get his side of the story then we
got his approval what he led in the wall
went in so I started having long phone
conversations with both of them on the
phone you know in those days he had the
extension one phone in one room of a
phone in another room and I took tons of
notes and he told me uh what was what he
told me about the trippity said the only
people on this trip are you me and your
father so I never want you to talk to
anyone else about me don't ever talk to
my family this is it what I tell you
that's it
you gotta promise me that I don't want
anything about the rest of my life in it
does maybe he was thinking of doing his
own book his own movie cuz people say oh
it's not enough about him it's exactly
what he wanted in so all that criticism
oh it's all about your father well yeah
of course it's about my father he told
me the story so I'm telling you it's for
my father's perspective how this guy
from the Bronx went on this trip with
this genius piano player but I didn't
have more dr. Shirley in it because he
didn't want it he said I don't
I only want you to tell from when I Met
Your father to when we were on the trip
together so that's what we told and he
also was a psychology major he had he
studied it and he so like he would tell
me that he would say things just to push
my father's buttons to see how he would
react as he said I never met anyone like
your father before so some things he
might have said or done maybe he didn't
really say or do outside of that but he
told my father so I just put in what he
told my father and me and then we have
it but their stories won't that
corroborated and he approved everything
that was gonna eventually be in the
script now dr. Shirley or your father
they died months apart yes Mike Woodson
exactly
Emily or dr. Cheu didn't get to see this
beautiful story I mean right they didn't
eat one of them gonna get but dr. Shawn
I didn't know about his family and I got
criticized for that too at the time I
didn't know about his family because in
1991 when he told me don't ever talk to
my family I mean he could have 10
brothers two brothers the only brother
he had mentioned was one so he told my
father yeah I got a brother somewhere so
I never at that time there was no look
at anyone up on the internet but even
years later when I was closer to making
the movie I didn't look up his family
because he told me not to do that when
you know that you're from New York
whew if I say to you I don't want you to
do this but you can tell my story but
you give me my work don't talk to my
family don't make it till after I die
die what would you do dun-dun-dun you
give you word your stand-up guy don't so
I gave them in my word I waited till
after he passed away he didn't want it
in there anything done till after that
and I also didn't reach out to anyone
because that's what he asked me to do
did the family come out after the movie
was released only came out afterwards
there was a lot of press about it saying
I didn't do my due diligence I didn't
talk to them which again put me in an
awkward position because he told me not
to talk to him and what more due
diligence could I do then talk to the
man himself so I did as much due
diligence as I could do but you gotta
remember this happened in 1962-63 I
talked to him about it in 1990-91 I
didn't start making the movie will start
we were writing a script with Peter
Farrelly and Brian curry to 2015 this is
you know 50 years I didn't know I didn't
look up the family this is the family
couldn't have told me anything about the
trip and I told them I wouldn't look up
the family so they were upset and I felt
bad about that but then they you know
they said something some kind of hurtful
things I don't think we're necessary but
there's nothing I could do about it
that's what I said I promised the guy
we'll talk to them but they reached out
to them they invited them to screenings
they even pre screenings before the
movie came out in New York they invited
listen
like to see it and even though you're
hearing about some of the family that
were mad there was a lot of family
members at friends said this is
beautiful
it's exactly how he was you guys
captured it perfectly I remember that
trip some people remembered it and so I
think for the most part most of them
were happy there were a few that weren't
but you're not gonna make everybody
happy at the end of the day no nobody's
gonna be I tried to make listen
rehearsal betrayal beautiful beautiful
man beautiful portrayal of the guy a
genius I think we showed him in showing
what it would it would a genius he was
listen no one would even know his name
right now you know would know who he is
no one know about the green book so it
wasn't a biopic of Don Shurley it was a
slow slice of life a little portion of
his life like my father little portion
of his life and everyone took great care
Peter finally everyone the from when we
wrote it to producing it to Pete
directing it and to my Hershel of
portraying him I think it was a
beautiful job the guy's known people are
downloading his music I mean he was sort
of a lost one of those lost guys that in
his time he was known but he wasn't like
a big big name outside of the jazz world
did in that in that classical sort of
world so I'm glad his name was out there
people know who he is
they know his music they know what the
Green Book is and then we made a pretty
the movies not that bad a won Best
Picture so we didn't do that I think it
was you know in a world where I like
certain [ __ ] movies Nick I don't go
see everything I want to see The
Avengers I want to see a lot of [ __ ]
hell unless he remakes I'm done I'm 56
I've seen though I've seen the good ones
and the bad ones and once you're in a
movie you see behind the curtain why a
movies made there's no capes you don't
see the Kings okay yeah so to me that
movie it came somewhere where hype you
know where I've been you know I was
telling people here that sometimes I say
the word Arab or whatever when I was in
college my tuna was Mohammed's a beep he
would come to my house I would go to his
house he
tell me about that culture so whatever
the [ __ ] you say it doesn't really
matter cuz I know the truth they're
sweet people so we've all gone through
that transition where we prejudge
somebody yes the way your family did it
was hilarious in the movie because
that's the way every family was you know
sure [ __ ] the two glasses I so crazy
[ __ ] yes I so crazy as [ __ ] you know I
to me I I in it reminded me of like just
like this movies used to have like a
point now and now like a lot of movies
out there are just like even I like
action movies but there's not it's just
it's a fun two hours with stuff blows up
and I like something where you learn
something you get trailing at like you
learn about that time you learn about
like I've heard about something like the
Green Book but seeing them go to the bar
when he gets drunk and the guys are
beating him I'm like wow that and then
the scene that I really liked was when
they were the car broke down and the
other guys were working in the field
that was like wow that those are the
scenes that they mean something to look
at when you watch Rocky you feel
something right they serve as you watch
you don't feel Bick well that's what I
want to do I love something I watched
you know I wanted to make a movie that
people felt something or net you know I
made a lot of crap before that but you
try you know I was kind of the minor
leagues of really making making lots of
independent movies never having enough
money whatever the excuses are but I
always wanted to make those type of
feel-good movies you know like Frank
Capra movie or you know the Bicycle
Thief or a Walt Disney movie the ones
that make you feel
there's alone for everything else I love
action movies I I like superhero movies
if they're good whatever it is if it's
entertaining that I think there's room
for everything but when I talked to
Brian curry about to bring him on to
write with me and then we went to Pete
we all you know wanted to make the movie
the touch people we're not solving
racism it's just a slice of life but
there's a little hope at the end of it
and it's it's a it's a story about human
beings and ever thought about black and
white just thought about two people and
that's how you should look at it so I
think
said we were very meticulous about the
script and then when Pete's Direction
was impeccable I mean he should have
been nominated for Best Director I like
that to me is a travesty has a movie get
nominated for best movie will it direct
itself do you know I mean I feel the
same way about Bradley Cooper he should
have got nominated for Best Picture the
movies the best picture that should be
you think if it's the best picture of
the director should be nominated nothing
against the other guys that got
nominated but how is Pete Farrelly not
nominated when this movie wins Best
Picture
something wrong there but my point is
peaked at a hell of a job we we all
cared about it
and it's filled with I think there's a
truthfulness to it despite what some
people think all those little incidents
really happen the only creative license
we took was it happened over a year and
a half period we moved them around Pete
wanted to concentrate it so we did it in
a two-month period eight one Christmas
but that's you know it's not it all
actually happened we just took all the
best stories and put them together and
we knew okay this is uh this is a true
story and I think that's why it
resonates that's why you feel something
because it's not a bunch of garbage so
let's not a lie you're feeling these
things happen these people really were
affected and you know these criticism
all of a sudden toneless character turns
around in two months well it wasn't two
months it was always a period of time
but yes he did turn around he changed
his life how he raised us how he treated
other people so um I was happy to I was
able to get that story of the screen and
the one I didn't understand the one that
the one that [ __ ] with me a little bit
wasn't it was funny and sad at the same
time not even funny is when he straight
out and he caught him at the Y or
whatever [ __ ] it's supposed to be right
you and I both know at that time period
people like you or me would have been
shocked like I would have been shocked
you know your dad didn't really judge
him at that period no at that time he
just walked out of there did your dad
tell you the story the doctor times they
both them and the thing was that's why
even you know life was calm
located and people are complicated so
you know the word racist I guess it
means one thing it's a lot of people so
you see something like the the glasses
at the beginning the oh that's a racist
mf'er you know but again I and this is a
I don't I don't like if there's no
excuses but one thing where how a person
is doesn't mean he's completely one way
or he's a bad heart or he has a he was a
it wasn't it wasn't a racist in the
sense he wasn't walking around with a
hood in his head he was a people person
he loved people human beings and he
didn't really judge people like my whole
life we were around all kinds of people
and he loved other people's cultures and
food and how they laughed how they
danced it didn't like how they dressed
he would love it if he saw something
didn't matter if you're black white
Jewish so even though in the culture and
you know growing up in New York and
stuff they were tribal groups be
everyone stay with their own kind but my
father what's he mixed with people he
treated them all the same and he brought
us up to do that so in that particular
sense like he says in the movie I've
been around nightclubs all my life I
know it's a complicated world he's he'd
gone and seen everything in the city
right he's in nightclubs he was working
at the wagon wheel and the peppermint
lounge he grew up knocking guys out he
was all over the place he saw it all so
he said he knew when he met Donna he
says I knew who's gay when I met him I
had a kid what do I care it's his
business
nothing doing me he was a nice guy to me
treated me fantastic so I was there to
protect him and I protected him I'm not
there to judge him what he wanted to do
what you don't want to do but I don't
want him going out without me because I
don't want him getting beaten up I don't
wanna get arrested I'm trying to in
those days he says in the movie you know
what would happen if this got out your
career and everything because they were
judged for that so he's had a good
with people even though who's this
rough-and-tumble guy and that's what
that see was about that and it really
happened so we put it in has there been
any thought to making a television show
der so you could go a little bit more
in-depth into some of the stories it's
never really come up you know you got to
get some cash one day I'll be very small
unless it's just how many scripted you
write before this
oh I had a bunch of a lot of independent
movies I mean that were made well uh
first movie was a movie called deadfall
with Nick Cage Michael Biehn Talia Shire
Peter Fonda was a good cast and all this
writing all through the years did you
ever thank the winning an Academy Award
did you ever think it was possible
was it something on the backburner
Awards it's something like me you never
even think about it just live your life
it wasn't like you just helped I'm gonna
win I'm gonna write an Academy Award
like any other kid or even just person
not even in the film industry
when you watched the Academy Awards
growing up you always think oh what
would I say if I was up there what what
would it be like to be up there or maybe
I'll be up there one day but not
actually when I was doing the work to do
something just trying to make the best
movies you can even if you're making a
crappy little movie I made a lot of
those I'm still trying to make something
good I never thought of Academy Awards
and when we started getting on this ride
it was a nice thought but you know to me
it sounds cliched the reward was like
that the movie made with a lot of big
people
it got seen the audience response was
unbelievable this Awards like sort of
campaign that was rough man that was
rough really though that was i I said
these people I mean ice to play ball
baseball and stuff and you win you win
you lose you lose you shake hands at the
end of the game that's how I was brought
up this is a brutal brutal people if
they could chop your head off they would
and I I got a little thrown off by that
and then I said we were getting attacked
on every level extend the surely family
we press oh he's lying
about this him and his father racists
you know Vito got attacked Pete Farley
got attacked I got attacked brutally
people trying to unlock the movie down
but how bad does it feel when somebody
calls you a lie crap and you know that
you're telling the truth and you really
don't give a [ __ ] you know like you like
if he thinks I'm lying I really don't
give a [ __ ] what he thinks I know what
happened up right now but like you know
I had to keep my mouth shut with a lot
of things because of the good of the
movie and the velocity because the more
you say noticed a couple things I tried
to explain even though I'm telling the
truth they twist it thicker so even when
I told the truth and a couple things
they said oh yeah that's convenient yeah
he didn't sure he's saying that now so
how do you win you can't win can't win I
don't even get into it there was a tweet
I made in 2015 about wherever I made it
about and they took they twisted it it's
not about what they said it was about
not what I meant to was what I was
talking about at all and I couldn't come
out and say a lesson well I meant at all
you're reading it wrong it's a tweet
something a fool is to take a look at
one of your tweets
well 2014 first of and some you to [ __ ]
up in one [ __ ] and one thing 140 word
right well first of all it shows you
that they were looking digging for so
that's the best that they could come up
with right some stupid tweet I made I'll
say what it was they were talking about
it was about one I guess Trump was
saying he saw Muslims cheering 9/11 on
rooftops said he saw it on the news so
then the news came out and said well not
he's nuts and he's lying because it was
never reported specifically CBS News he
said I think I saw it on CBS not like
that I used to work for CBS News - the
9/11 was crazy in New York is we win the
tri-state area was devastated and on CBS
News they reported that this was going
on now whatever I saw it watchh 2014-15
they said oh it was never reported so
for some stupid reason that God but I
wasn't pissed at the news I mean how
could they lie about that whether it
happened at night I don't know I didn't
see it happen I saw the news report that
said it happened the news report said it
happened so all I said was but I wrote
it you know I said yeah hundred percent
correct cheering going on I think I saw
it in CBS News they came out and said
I'm racist and um and and Islamophobic
rants and tweets
well first was one tweet no one has a
making racist I didn't say I I just said
I saw something on television I saw the
news report on television that's it but
because it was a tweet I could only
write so many words if I know I was
right if I don't want a dissertation I
would have said oh yes I also saw the
news report that said that on TV it was
on channel 2 crazy what went on with
that is just insane
which shows they could say into anything
so I didn't say anything about it
because for the good of the movie they
didn't want me to say nothing I want to
defend myself and say well what they're
saying is not the truth I'm being
accused of something I didn't do or
didn't mean wasn't even in my heart mind
or soul what they're saying and and
that's what happened so taught me a
great lesson luckily I was not a real
tweeter I think I only did 20 tweets so
in my whole life about come see this
movie go see my movie that one in
particular pissed me off because I
thought how could a news organization
lie and say wasn't on the air another
one on YouTube I found it I found I
found the news report it was on people
everyone else that knows we saw it
people in Jersey and I get a lot of
people don't know we said I saw that but
so what I saw it on TV
what is that was a wheel saw planes in a
building we saw the World Series being
one well if I said yeah I won though I
saw I saw the the the Red Sox were in
the World Series I saw it on television
but I didn't do it you know I mean this
bizarre so
come after you even when you win the
[ __ ] right so it was it was a tough
time it kind of took the the fun out of
it for me and but it didn't didn't stop
the movie and the movie did well because
I think people saw most people saw
through that I think it's a small
minority and and the people that report
that stuff aren't real journalists the
real journalists I read a lot of good
ones along the strip and they're they're
good people and they have brains in
their head and they they they ask both
sides of the story this was just attack
attack attack attack and you know what
I'm a big boy
I could take it I dealt with it I said
whatever I don't care what they think so
nikka [ __ ] Academy Award won two
Academy Awards you know same Academy
Award this is know when you were writing
it who are you thinking of for the lead
when you were right I knew it had been
Italian before I met with Pete and Brian
a couple years before when I was first
thinking about it I talked to James
Gandolfini about it and he loved it and
I was thinking I was was I thinking we
were gonna pursue that unfortunately he
passed away so after you passed away
again I put him sort of on the side
burner it's like my father had passed
away the same Gandolfini last time I saw
was at my father's funeral
four or five months later he passed away
too so it was really a rough sort of
time for me and then when I started
doing it again with Brian curry and
Peter Farrelly lots of names came up
and we we talked to a lot of different
people and peeping out with some people
then it was Pete that King came to me
and said we're about vegan Mortensen and
I think more since one of my favorite
actors of all time and I went wow the
bigger ones don't believe like somewhat
peanut there's something about I think
the guy's got to be Italian or at least
half Italian or have some of that
sensibility because you know you start
doing a bad New York Italian town it's
like a Saturday Night Live skit where I
know some guys imitating Joe Pesci badly
you know so I thought about it like
someone you know what who's the most
iconic Italian character ever put on
film
what's the Godfather if you
who's the biggest The Godfather Marlon
Brando not Italian Melrose Irish maybe
mixed whatever he is but no time I said
you know what Viggo is like I'm Marlon
Brando and I said Pete I think you're
onto something I think he can do it I
pictured it in my head and Vigo man what
a job he did that's my father you watch
that movie that's exactly my father how
he was one at that age Vigo studied film
tape luckily there was my father later
in life was an actor so we watched the
Pope he watch The Sopranos he watched
everything my father was in listen to
the tapes that I recorded of my father
telling story and he just gained 45
pounds hung out with me and my brother
and my uncles he picked up not only the
Bronx accent but when he spoke in
Italian my father his family had it they
were from Calabria so the Calabrian
accent mixed with the Bronx had its own
sort of dialect you know and Vigo was
right on it
but that was Pete's idea it turned out
brilliantly what were you what did you
start off as well you went to college I
went to college yeah what kind of degree
communications did you think you were
gonna write it off yeah I always was
writing for my little game I wrote
little books I wrote little stories I
was writing and watching you dad acted
that inspired you to act or yeah yeah
yeah I guess so yeah but I loved it for
like I said for when I was 10 I always
knew I wanted to be an actor I don't
know why it's not the smartest Godfather
did you do a bunch of stuff III wasn't
like a kid actor I did the Godfather but
that was the thing that got me like film
you know filmmaking so I was always
making little films and those days there
literally caught him with scissors put
them together and wood fire yeah so I
used to make tiny little little movies
and then in high school I was the only
kid that took the film class and not go
to sleep so I watched the film teacher
was excited about that all finally one
of these kids gives a crap so he would
show me Citizen Kane and it's a
wonderful life and all these great
movies and learn about editing then I
became an usher in a movie theater I'd
watch movies over and over and over blue
that was like a film school onto itself
cuz I say okay now I'll watch how they
edited now I watch just the acting now
I'll watch the action sequences so every
movie because those days the movies
there for nine months so you watched
hundreds of times so I just loved love
film and I always do we want to get into
it so no it's college communications
studied film and TV
I was acting during college I started
doing the extra work in New York
off-broadway I did a lot lots and lots
of theater how long did you kick around
New York I was from from right out of
high school even when I was in college I
was doing stuff from New York so what I
was almost thirty and then I moved to LA
only you moved to LA what did you want
to do well same thing I knew how to get
out here and get to and get it
how long plea you sold your first script
I saw the script length very quickly
really as soon as I get out so I got
here I got a play I got I got a TV show
and I saw the script like right away
just boom so I but then after that I
went downhill for a while but when I
first got here went good and what do you
mean downhill well then it was it was it
was the struggle you know I was back
trying to get movies made write some
more scripts I was getting a little ones
done here and there but I was like
working in clubs I was doorman in the
West one the clubs in LA were big-time
with lines down the block
working in all the hot hot clubs which
was good and bad but meeting different
people and then still continuing to do
some whatever Little Theater was in Los
Angeles and I'm writing and directing
and producing little indie movies I was
type of guy oh I'm not getting casted
something I'll write something put
myself in and make it myself that's how
I was so I I did a bunch of those that
movie's good for you man you never
stopped just keep going and you the
thing I like about you is that you
[ __ ] you're Renaissance man you act
for two weeks then right for two weeks
then go here for two weeks you went to
the Kentucky Derby well there's things
like you like singing about guys like
we know jack of all trades master of
none but I like doing lots of different
to me it's all one thing is art and you
know like you see guys like us that
people think oh they think they're
actors but it it is a Renaissance man in
the sense of I I never wanted a
pigeonhole myself and I liked lots of
different things you know I did some
musical theater sang I danced I just
love the arts I guess but when you say
that in your a big mug they think you're
a [ __ ] but I you know I studied it read
about it I like I like all kinds of
literature film books and so you know
drama comedy a little bit of everything
so why can't you do everything you know
what I mean if it's fun and you like
doing it and you do it fairly okay why
not when the movie hit the theater and
you saw the response what did you feel
like it was very one thing to act in
something that very emotional very
emotional I think we all did it was kind
of weird Pete everyone would get choked
up at the end of that movie you see
people in the theater crying crying at
the end of the thing and and and and
hushed in other parts and laughing and
it's when you achieve that when those
are the scenes you wanted them to laugh
and those are the scenes you one of them
hushed those are the scenes you want
them to cry and it's working like that
you know it's where I'm in the movie I
play the mob guy that my father's
character be who goes to see in the
restaurant I forget him in the movie
because Timmy knows more about the movie
as a whole and how it affected people in
the Chinese Bartling the shot to see
that was another little touch that was
actually my brother remind me that and
when I said oh we do the scene of Joan
Jones because remember dad would take us
everyone was always a Chinese Borton
even in Italian restaurants in the Bronx
and I'm like that's right every
bartender was Chinese and the Italian
restaurants for some reason well it did
just were there so I told that to Peter
Farrell and he goes home get a Chinese
bartender who's and just the fact that
the guy said to a a white guy to shut up
I think a head to head with a bar shows
you the power of the bartender yeah and
he's a guy from the Bronx Chinese are
not Chinese tonight he was a proxy guy
so he's not taking crap from anybody to
me the highlight that hit home with me
was when he just broke it down from
about you know he was from the Bronx is
Louis from the Bronx his father's from
the Bronx you know that he knew who the
[ __ ] he was that was the emotional
highlight for me that made me cry more
than the ending because it's very
important in this life to know who the
[ __ ] you are and to stop playing games
yourself thinking that you're rich or
whatever you know your dad in that film
Tony Webb his character he was kind of
insulted when he didn't know who the
[ __ ] you know I don't you know this
[ __ ] bad
these are your people doc right you know
when you say these are your people in
today's world back the run uses from
racist and I say that you know the Zeen
[ __ ] but I don't you [ __ ] know you
know how don't you [ __ ] it saying right
now you put on Willie Cologne for me
then you go Joey
how don't you know this this is these
guys are your people I wouldn't get a
friend into that but me that was the
part of the movie that at home I wanted
people that were watching it to
understand what the [ __ ] he was coming
from right because people he said they
take it the world they people now take
that are the same thing with that fried
chicken mass with masterpiece
controversies I go to [ __ ] Tennessee
and that's the first place I go the
fried chicken place
it was Kentucky Fried Chicken in
Kentucky and when he says that line so
what doc this is you know your food the
same type of thing about these music is
you see people miss later on they go to
they go to a plantation when he's
playing and they serve up Fried Chicken
now that's racist because they said oh
the bark I give him fried chicken well
my father's saying it's a different
whole different thing he's saying what
do you mean you don't never had this and
whether he had it or not I don't know
but he said he'd never had it this food
is great the collard greens he says the
collard greens is mistake the the black
chef's made it for me I love it
you say I like spaghetti meatballs I'm
not insulted its food I'll give you my
food I like your food is cultures it's
all good so he's not saying it in a
hurtful prejudiced way he's just that's
the way it was he was like well this is
life food he said it was a guy food
eating drinking laughing talking smoking
he enjoyed life it's right Carly it's
not gonna send the car and I talk to the
guy the guy who want to talk you want to
just sit in the backseat
the only talking [ __ ] driving so
[ __ ] across the country we're not
gonna talk not open we don't want to eat
while I'm driving
blue blew his mind but my father I'm
here you know we're here together let's
make the best of it let's have some fun
so that's how he was but that was part
of two people today that don't know this
or offended by it they need to see it
because this is how it was this is how
people war that doesn't make everyone
you know shouldn't be judged by one
incident or one thing that they say
there's people are complex you know I
mean there's a lot going on and that's
how my father was he was a complex guy
you know I read somewhere that one of
the magazine called it one of the top
buddy movies the something was a rolling
stone yeah I think so yes we're talking
about a movie [ __ ] 48 hours didn't
get this much slide right he called him
a watermelon he smacked him you know he
abusive yes things to Eddie Murphy and
at the end again they it was nothing
will peeling cool the skin to get to the
[ __ ] better yes that's what we're
doing they were peeling through the skin
just to get to the banana at the end of
the day you know I'm solid and I know
you're [ __ ] solid and that's it
you know we've we've been on here for a
little while and the racism part of this
movie which I didn't see in ads at all
has come up I didn't see it that way at
all Nick I didn't feel like when I
watched Planet of the Apes just last
time when they got rereleased I'm the
movie theater and they're 55 it finally
hit me whoever wrote this is [ __ ]
racist you know saying whoever wrote
Planet of the Apes have you watched the
early ones from 1969 you like they had
to be
[ __ ] racism makes it marijuana in
there well I think that was on purpose I
think that they were trying to show show
that the the racism in a real world that
people the differences will really work
all the same my old thing is we're all
same I don't think of race me neither
I don't the first time I heard was they
gave all on Brando some job interview
and said you know put down race he put
down human that's what it was human race
well the same we're all the same in the
eyes of God as far as I'm concerned
culturally this difference is this
cultures but that's you know whatever
but I don't think with anyone is
different so as much as I got accused of
otherwise so uh but in history and in
time these things went on we need to
show it I mean this movie handled race
in a certain way again a little slice of
life life movie about two people
Spike Lee had black Klansmen it handled
race in a different way there's lots of
stories about race they all should be
told some are more serious some could do
it with some humor but it's still
serious I think you know as much as the
movies funny green book and there's a
lot that comes from human beings are
funny right and people I think there was
some horrific scenes in there showing
how the races and the he had to deal
with during that time and my father saw
happening and going holy [ __ ] I wouldn't
take this [ __ ] and realizing well this
guy's taking it for a reason he saw how
horrible it was we were seeing it with
his own eyes and that's what changed so
that's what the so did your dad and your
dad punched a bank one second that was
also shows the other side of the view
that was a beautiful scene right that
should have and was included in then it
makes the movie completely to store to
show you what was really going on on
both sides of the [ __ ] thing do they
really call Bobby Kennedy absolutely no
[ __ ]
absolutely where's the where's the the
Academy Award now
I got two of them because I won Best
Screenplay and I produce it so Best
Picture I got I got one also so it's
Italian from the brown
New Jersey get two Academy Awards who
would have [ __ ] thought that's it's
insane my least favorite part of school
was when they were handing back a test
and I my lasting Messiah so I would
always get the test back last what was
it like when like you see that the like
your categories are coming up and you're
waiting for them to announce it like are
you like sweating bullets or you just
you don't care or like what like what is
that like when you're waiting there well
I'll be honest with you because of all
the crap I went through with this tweet
and all the controversy on that and
everything else I really didn't enjoy
the Academy Awards I didn't want to be
there I say now I'm glad I went and I'm
glad what happened I was on edge the
whole time I always almost like what if
I get booked if I win what if I get
booed off the stage I got to know how
people felt so it was a way it was a
weird vibe for me uh it wasn't how you
know you dreamed about it so because of
all that stuff so it took a lot of it
but when it came up and first one was
screenplay and.and for me and when my
hearse Allah had won for Best Supporting
Actor I was so proud of that but one at
one I thought of my father and my
parents and family people know mom and
dad a gun though yeah and like you know
and what not like I thought what I went
through my whole life but how people
supported me and aunts and uncles and
and family and friends that always said
keep going and keep going keep going so
then I felt good you know and then it's
won Best Picture
I I kind of didn't listen were there
we're nominee you want to win you think
you can win I thought well you know it's
the best picture in my heart no matter
what happens but that was the one that
really shocked me I was like shocked me
in a good way I was like wow this is I
mean I want to carry me wards it's crazy
in this business at least that's the
pinnacle that you're gonna get to I
think there's lots more important things
in life but if you're in this business
that those things are held in such high
regard it's it's them does it get any
better it's like a two Golden Globes two
Academy Awards and we want some other
things along the way
quite a ride quite an experience I mean
I got to thank my father for it's my
father story it's my father still
helping me from from upstairs you know I
mean well you know I always say
something really weird Nexen I thought
about this with you when I found out you
wrote it love about we sit here for
years as writers or whatever the [ __ ]
and I see it all the time people write
about [ __ ] they're not really connected
to you know oh I always like sharks and
you write a movie about sharks and we
end up doing that piece-of-shit movie
about sharks and New Jersey attacking
people but sometimes the best story is
the simplest one there's the one that we
could tell with our eyes cause I mean
while I was sitting there trying to
write the next big Academy Award winner
I think you learned something because I
feel the same way yeah you know I sold
the TV show last year
I love the writers but what they wrote
wasn't my life they took it you did what
they want when you stand up you doing
what comes out of you right right and I
think most stand-ups I need to tell me
if I'm wrong the ones emitted
if you go back Lenny Bruce and Pryor and
Carla man and all that dice and
Maniscalco you are guys that are talking
about what they know their family their
friends their life experience so I think
it's the same thing what you're talking
about this this movie was something I
knew it came from my heart my family but
comedy same thing I mean these guys have
good joke writers and there's there's
room for that too but the guys that
really resonate are the ones that are
coming from their own inside and their
heart good or bad they'd given it to you
you know and I think that's that's it
makes for the best type of material I'm
happy that you're happy that you put out
I mean last year's best [ __ ] work you
know I'm happy that you saw the
simplicity for years you wrote about
satellites and Martian [ __ ] that a
rule is getting beat up but the story
that shine the monsters do one on the
I'm trying to say yeah is that your
right how long do you mean from 91 was
when you first [ __ ] tape-recorded dr.
Shirley yeah that's and all that how
long did you hold onto those cassettes
did you oh I still have but did you glad
peter farrelly hurt him Brian Currier
not writing this already 92 I had over
the years I guess I had lots of notes I
wrote treatments I wrote I wrote sort of
breakdowns of beginning middle ends so I
had a lot of material so when I when I
told Brian about it he told Pete I had a
lot to story telling your dad you would
definitely not do this before he passed
he was oh he knew for my whole life but
he knew couldn't do it till after dr.
shirlee passed away so that's why I
never did I got approached a couple
times to do it
and I even got said to change the names
change the names the story saw
unbelievable change the names I don't
want to do that Tim and I couple times
it was broken I couldn't made a lot of
money I was with the Private Eye my
Brandon Tartikoff president of Paramount
I'm in his office so I'll do this right
now let's do it who doesn't want to be
with the head of paramount I was like
working at nightclubs
but I said then I promised the guy I
promised the guy I wouldn't do it so
after he passed so I didn't want to do
that
you know and you promised dr. Shirley
you would not do it though he got me he
went on to get married and stuff right
no no he stayed no no I think he was
married like in the 40s or before the
move like he was telling them that he
was married for 10 years if the user can
yeah everything fit but they no no then
he never got well what I know why didn't
he want the story bug till he was dead
he didn't tell me it could have been
because of the the gay thing and I
respect that because he was still from
an era that you know he never I don't
think he ever came out publicly about
that and if that's what that was the
reason whatever the reason was but that
that's what I just respect to when he
asked me so Nick you went from Long
Island shark attack the Jersey Shore to
an Oscar and Golden Globe what advice do
you have for young writers who you have
anything like well did you take a
writing course did you read a writing
book would you just look to other
scripts on the scripts I read books on
writing I've read you know the famous
one William Goldman's book Adventures of
the screen trade I read later on a
Stephen King's book on writing great
book but that was like later when I
first started when I first wanted to
write a script
there was a book of screenwriting format
I just looked that was a typewriter I
just looked at okay you put dialog here
you put this here and I'm still looking
at scripts I mean I just said okay this
is how they do it interior means inside
exterior means outside and it sounds
stupid and simple but maybe you don't
know and luckily my father was doing
some movies so he'd bring scripts home
from me he said read this look at this
you know so he helped me and encouraged
me in that way so I you know just kind
of in me always do it but I would say to
anyone doing it don't give up before
ever anything you know I've been doing
this a long time banging around forever
and you know I hit this point now so
maybe all downhill from here who knows
you know like it doesn't really matter
you made your point
maybe it wasn't in the way you want it
to maybe you want to [ __ ] Angelina Jolie
in a movie like that but you you came a
long way you're a kid from Jersey and
the Bronx that grew up on everything
from jailhouse rock then to [ __ ] The
Exorcist and you got your shot and it
came through and you wrote something
that was deep in your heart you kept to
form you didn't break no promises he
then saw your soul along the way to make
a script well why don't you make his
wife black I'm playing the bongos cuz
yeah as you know when you were writing
this you run into a bunch of geniuses
yeah and they try to take it it's so
weird I think it was donnell rawlings I
saw him on a radio interview on tour and
he was saying you know when you get here
as
comic they tell you what to say your
agents come up to you and say you gotta
go up there and do material on the
sitcom and comics get [ __ ] up they get
[ __ ] up they want to go up then sell
the TV shows now they're talking about
the grandmother and how are you like
last week you were talking about
something some chicks oh and now you're
talking about your grandma and your
[ __ ] three-year-old kid and then they
go away and they realize they should
have stuck to their guns do you know I'm
saying yeah and I think the same thing
happened you're right I think the thing
happened with you where you add this all
your life you put it out there and now
what's the [ __ ] thing and your dad
looks great you know your dad ended up
looking beautiful I'm very proud of it I
can't be happy I mean make family proud
people see it love it I got to work with
great people I mean Peter Farrelly Viggo
Mortensen rehearsal we Linda Cardellini
Sebastian everybody really involved in
it cared about it everyone knew this is
Johnny roast beef Johnny roast beef
great scene where'd you both have died
the [ __ ] meatball playthrough well I
know him forever and the good friend of
my father's and I he was in Rao's I
brought Peter Farrelly into rails to see
him you know and once Peter goes we got
to put him in a movie yeah you know yeah
the guy eating the hot dogs cuz of
course perfect perfect guy for that so
it was nice you know I had some other
friends and family my brothers in the
movie my uncles are in the movie the
grandfathers are both my real uncles
playing their own fathers in the movie
my brother plays Vigo's brother so it
was the Pete was very generous in that
way that he let me be creative with him
and collaborate with him he ended up
picking everybody and doing everything
but he let me bring a lot to the movie
so it was great in that way and you know
what the best picture I got a stage
Julia Roberts handed me my Oscar and
gave me a kiss who's better than that
nobody one last thing about your dad
your dad is me he's I can for my
favorite movies I did not know he was in
29th Street oh yeah I did not remember
that I remember exactly what it was he
gets shot at the beginning of the year
the dragon yes I got the good [ __ ]
there's a cigar yes yes Chinese good
[ __ ]
you and your cousin you know my [ __ ]
cousin is exactly [ __ ] you and your
[ __ ] cousin
well skinny [ __ ] Chinese guy
delivering spareribs yeah and then I was
an interesting movie a lot of people
don't know about that yeah under under a
movie you know written by by Oliver
Stone and directed by Michael Jimmy no a
very underrated nobody talked about that
move anymore not at all
29th Street one of my all-time faves
Gallo the best one of my all-time frame
out was your dad in that really long
yeah Louie bad lungs or something he had
a big sequence I think most we got cut
out but he's in there they'd show me
they totally walnuts Vinnie Kurt oh yeah
a lot of guys from you know Anthony
LaPaglia right ugly yeah the other kid
that played his cousin was in The
Sopranos at the end yes he played one of
the hitmen in season seven he went after
Silvio yeah I never saw that guy again
his cousin was connected yes seven the
him 29th Street you could always go to
people yes and 29th it was Frank
pecheurs true sprang bashes true story
yeah so there's no bump in the fray nice
to see him I just saw him about six
months ago on game on somewhere what a
[ __ ] was it you remember we did so he
did he pulled it off Frank patch you
know the that was a great movie he loved
that movie
Chad's pulled it off chairs made a movie
but it was very chairs was great to me
voluntary throughout this whole thing
because he was the only guy could really
talk about that was going through this
on this level of a movie but he did it
you know with his story too so he was
great to talk to and he read the script
and actually George gallo May 29th
Street and chasm the only two guys I
gave the script in to say what do you
guys think you know I loved it man I'm
really happy for you
he's really good reconnecting with you
oh I hope we didn't boil your audience
this wasn't a laugh Phil no no no they'd
have to see a soft side of you that they
don't normally get to so no no I said
what did he run out of a times
interviews I want
nobody left in Hollywood I think that
you're very interesting I think you're
splitting the [ __ ] sensational you
make your first Academy Award when I've
ever had this [ __ ] something I
like I thought I give you a lot of
respect Nick I like what you did I
respect how much you love your dad my
dad died when I was three I wish you
know there's a lot of things about this
movie that connected with me well
there's nice ways my first friend when I
came from Cuba was a black car on 25th
Street and I didn't know anything about
color I still remember walking miles to
go by James Brown hot pants in 1969 we
were kids you know walking in a [ __ ]
Broadway in New York huh and I didn't
know I was supposed to be racist do you
know I was like I didn't know I didn't
get that [ __ ] memo as a Cuban that I
wasn't supposed to like some [ __ ]
black and I found that over the years
and I'm like why wouldn't I like this
guy so the movie just hit with me and I
think you're a sweetheart of a [ __ ]
guy and I wish you all the luck in the
world you know you ain't got no more mob
movies I have no reason to have you
particular job well you never know happy
you took time to come on I appreciate
you having me and I was telling me I was
saying I was doing the show you are it
shows great we're gonna have a great
time I tell you how long the seat you
know people never we never get to talk
to Academy award-winning right whatever
so I want people to know that you're a
guy from the you know this podcast is
about letting [ __ ] know they
could do anything yeah don't let them
hold you back and you're a guy that they
could I said I'm from Jersey little
[ __ ] oh look at me I'm from the Bronx
you're here brother so thank you long
journey do not forget I will be at the
Ice House jeweled first and then at the
Fillmore in New Orleans on the seventh
and then at the Tabernacle Theatre in
Atlanta on the eighth all right now for
a word from our sponsors all right I
want to thank my man Nick Vala langa and
don't forget to watch the Green Book
it's that good of a movie if you haven't
watched it I want to thank the
[ __ ] but most importantly I
want to thank you [ __ ] for
listening
and believe it is in us that's why we
try so hard to bring you the best
product that we [ __ ] care speaking of
products manscape that card let me tell
you something you have asked your wife
or your girlfriend to trim your nutsack
and you're sitting there looking at the
wall make him believe like this is the
last dam like it dick is flying off you
see the blood coming out of the hole
like one of those [ __ ] burning what
what's that show everybody likes
everybody walking around naked walking
down yeah your dicks looking like
walking dead you ever see when they cut
one of their heads off the next little
stem out that's what you see between
your legs is somebody's trimming your
hair well guess what the fear is over
uncle Joey's here to tell you don't cut
off your dick and nobody's gonna cut her
off to you why because the manscape you
get it done without the pain without the
anxiety without the [ __ ] drama their
invention is the lawnmower and handheld
razor with skin safe technology so it
won't snick or snag your sack no [ __ ]
bruises you mean your nutsack with a
hammer no more ice cream you gotta go
easy on what the Lord gave you this bad
boy will leave you clean smooth and pain
and anxiety free plus its rechargeable
me very easy to hold get it into all the
nooks and crannies that's where the
sting start that's where everything they
got everything for you pick your leg up
and you shave between your nutsack and
your [ __ ] that's the [ __ ]
stinkville you can trim those [ __ ]
hairs you know I'm saying you got the
little hair that sticks out of your
jeans coming out of your [ __ ] you
could trim that [ __ ] - with
confidence with manscaped tools I'm not
gonna I'm gonna let you in on a little
secret if you trim the hedges the tree
looks a lot taller so if you got like a
4-inch dick and you take off the hair
it's a six inch dick that's how easy
this is trim on that [ __ ] egg roll and
manscape calm you get everything you
need to make your ball shine and keep
your dick looking like [ __ ] Pierre
for moi if this is your first time
considering manscape then get the deal
they got for you you ready it's called
the perfect package it comes with a
lawnmower and a safety razor plus the
crop preserver
especially formulated the Ottoman so
your balls don't stink like a [ __ ]
camel and to the Reviver
a spritz that tones and refreshes your
nutsack and your dick and all that area
down there they keep you nice and cool
at summertime you want to keep the
[ __ ] that area nice and cool that's
it the perfect package has the store for
you now the church family gets 20% off
again 20% on Joey you [ __ ] kidding me
20% off with your first order when you
use promo code Church CH you are CH at
manscape comm and if you order the
perfect package that we discussed to
also throw in a free beautiful little
travel bag when you use promo code
Church who's better than manscape calm
no body they're gonna make it dick in
your ball sack and all that area look
[ __ ] tip-top Magoo like it's calling
the [ __ ] Oscars you understand me so
do me a favor that's manscape comm you
promo code church and get 20% off your
first order you can't beat this [ __ ]
deal from manscape keep your ballsack
nice and clean go to manscape comm
number two I want to thank on it for
making the best supplements out there in
the business how do I know cuz I'm
[ __ ] living proof I got on 22 planes
a month you understand me from time to
time I get sick but I reduce the odds of
getting sick why shroom tech
[ __ ] a meal that's why Schrute
export shroom tech immune they had a way
to go and listen you're a little off
your little [ __ ] up you got hit in the
head with a [ __ ] stick when you were
four you want to adjust your brain
chemistry alpha brain is the way to go
why do I tell you because has a hundred
percent money-back guarantee if you're
not satisfied with the product and they
don't want the product back that's a
company I can stand behind you
understand me
they got kettle bells and I got club
bells and all that stuff I can't help
you with that as far as supplements are
concerned I got you back and guess what
you get 10% off when you press in church
and it gets live at the house you're not
thinking oh [ __ ] that now food store and
get it and wait online and give me your
point number listen you want to start
living better go to honey calm right now
impressing church get 10% off one of our
tremendous supplements delivered right
the house it's that easy it's that
simple all right so I want to thank
manscape comm again and I want to thank
on ted.com for always being there but I
want to thank you guys for support
and for being the bad [ __ ] that
you are I love you [ __ ] have a
happy Memorial Day stay safe and we'll
see you [ __ ] Monday Memorial
Day nice and early waiting for you so
you're not lonely all right I love you
guys have a great weekend god bless you
kick this [ __ ] mule e-easy no drama
brother I was worried it wasn't funny
enough I don't I know you